[Music]
kovat 19 has affected the entire world
it's infected millions and killed
hundreds of thousands not only that but
it's also changed the way we live work
and interact with others when will
things finally get back to normal
well for some people that might not be
until a vaccine is developed which could
take up to two years or more
what will your life be like until then
what would this vaccine do to your body
and when will things start to go back to
normal this is what if and here's what
would happen if it takes two years for a
kovat 19 vaccine a köppen 19 vaccine
will try to train our immune system the
idea is to harmlessly show the virus to
your body to help it recognize and fight
it so that when you encounter the
disease in real life your body will know
how to fight covin 19 right now we know
the genetic code of the virus which is
extremely helpful for developing a
vaccine but scientists still have a lot
to learn which is why experts think we
may not see a vaccine for up to two
years so what will our lives be like
until then
if the kovat 19 pandemic continues for
another two years don't expect things to
completely go back to what you're used
to but you won't be locked in your home
for another two years either it's likely
that with most of the world being under
quarantine new cases of kovat 19 will
reduce and when that number decreases
enough governments may choose to open
their economies back up some governments
may choose to do this sooner than they
should so people can go back to work and
ease the unemployment problem something
you might see in retail stores are
disinfecting robots some will be able to
clean with disinfectant while others
will have UV light attachments as that's
a potential way to kill kovat 19 on
surfaces even with most stores reopening
don't expect to be in any crowded malls
or restaurants right away reopening
businesses will be a slow process as we
see in grocery stores right now the
number of customers allowed in at one
time will likely be limited you may also
have to wait in line before you can go
inside and while you're in these stores
it will still be important to maintain a
physical distance of at least two meters
that's six feet handshakes hugs and any
other forms of touching and public will
no longer be normal what will likely be
normal is everyone wearing masks they
may even become fashionable as brands
will hope to earn money on the fact that
everyone will need one of these if they
want to go out and if you have to travel
in the next two years expects to take
even more precautions airports are
beginning to test full-body disinfection
devices these are meant to disinfect a
user within 40 seconds killing any
viruses you may have on your skin or
your clothes
and before you board your plane you may
have to take a rapid kovat nineteen
blood tests these will produce test
results in just 10 minutes
before you board your plane people who
definitely won't be traveling will be
those who have a pre-existing condition
as they'll need to be especially careful
without a kovat 19 vaccine they'll still
have the highest risk of dying if they
catch the disease if the economy slowly
starts to reopen and we don't see an
uptick in the number of new cases you
can expect to see more stores reopen and
even public spaces like parks and
beaches not only that but there's a
chance schools could reopen as well
eventually they may even become an
essential service social distancing
etiquette and learning how to wash your
hands properly will start to become part
of the school curriculum but even with
all these reopening don't expect to go
to any concerts or sporting events since
large crowds make it easier for kovat 19
to spread you can look forward to all
that after you've been vaccinated and if
you've been working from home all this
time you might continue to even after
the vaccine is available your company
may realize that there's no need for
office space anymore but what about the
people who still can't go back to work
remember when stores do reopen they'll
have fewer customers in the store and
they'll also have fewer employees
millions of people will still be out of
work due to their health or their
company not being able to rehire them
this will further expand the need to
create a universal basic income
this allows people to get a set amount
of money each month regardless of
whether or not they're working but this
is if everything goes according to plan
right now how to safely restart our
economies is still largely a mystery a
second wave of kovat 19 could happen if
governments and people aren't careful
enough if we do see a second wave all
governments around the world may begin
to track their citizens with bank
records and phone usage in order to stop
the spread they could find out who to
test if they know who's been outside
more than they should have been or who's
been in large gatherings now if we don't
see a second wave of kovat 19 this way
of life could be our world's new normal
at least until we've all been vaccinated
and we're hoping that happens in less
than two years according to the World
Health Organization more than 70 teams
of doctors and scientists are working to
develop a kovat 19 vaccine some are
being tested in humans right now once we
know a vaccine works we'll need to make
a lot of it and distribute it around the
world after that hopefully the world can
go back to normal I wonder if there's a
better way to fight off kovat 19 other
than a vaccine maybe we could use UV
lights
but we'll leave that story for another
what-if